if that you're doing a bare minimum if  you go to like those visits  but it's kind of like why are we  diminishing like men being involved in  their kids lives like i think that's  almost diminishing it  i don't think it's diminishing but i  just think because men men pet like like  the woman can  there's like it's good for the baby if  they hear the dad around and stuff you  know  and like men still have to financially  support it more times than not  i do that that's true but like i do feel  like nothing will like it will never  match up like what the woman does in  that whole biological process in  comparison to what the man does like  physically we list the things physically  what did they do they're literally  carrying the child like nine months  other than carrying the child what did  they do  they're literally like using their own  body as like a life you realize like  dogs do that like everyone like  every every animal carries  like